MALE SPEAKER: Hi Everybody.
I'm joined in the studio
today, on-site at Founder World
in San Francisco, by
astronaut Yvonne Cagle.
Aerospace medical engineer,
electrical, biotechnology
wearables-- you have a lot
going on right now in your life.
What excites you?
YVONNE CAGLE: What excites me
is the endless possibilities,
that anything is possible.
That when you take
things off planet,
then the sky is no
longer the limit.
And the best part is things that
we discover off planet in space
oftentimes have real world
applications right back here
on Earth.
So we can even have the win
in developing and innovating
even before we step off planet.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
really exciting.
Can you give an
example of something
that you're working
on right now that has
that practical application?
YVONNE CAGLE: Well
we're looking at mission
to Mars within the NASA
agency, and so we're
studying behavioral performance,
how we can make sure
that we're able
to have resiliency
when it comes to behavioral
performance on long duration
crews.
So we can keep crews
working together,
that we can keep crews sharp
and stimulated in their thinking
and environment that can be very
isolating and sensory deprived.
And that we can really
make sure that we support
the reintegration, so
that if, by choice, we
want to get back in line and go
to Neptune or even Pluto now,
we're up to the task.
MALE SPEAKER: That is
really exciting stuff.
So you're also a professor.
What type of things are
you teaching your students
that kind of line up with
your aerospace career?
YVONNE CAGLE: Well, the
most important thing
in behavioral performance is
really thinking out of the box,
and looking at what your tools
are right here on Earth that
might have relevance in
space, and, again, how
you can use space to
develop a platform
to demonstrate capabilities
that we need here on Earth.
So for example,
some of my students
are occupational
therapy students,
and they're using
occupational science
to use some of the same
strategies and tools
to rehabilitate challenging
conditions for performance
and learning, here
on Earth, for crews
as they go into long duration.
As well as games and
other ways to entertain
when you're in that kind
of challenged environment.
MALE SPEAKER:
That's really cool.
So you just came
off the main stage,
giving the opening
keynote talk at the event.
What was the message
that you were trying
to get across to the audience?
YVONNE CAGLE: The
message was really
the next big leap is what
our big thinking should
be about, and
knowing that everyone
can participate in that.
I myself am working with a
very exciting team of engineers
in Silicon Valley on
wearable technologies,
finding strategies to
recondition astronauts,
and even people here on
Earth who are deconditioned,
infirmed, or just
discouraged-- who
want to either stay or
amplify-- kind of enhance--
or just get back in the game.
And so the things
that we discover
are immediately relevant.
And the big message
that I wanted
to make sure everyone
came away with,
is be bold to dare to engage
your ideas and to innovate.
Because that iteration,
that innovation,
is definitely here on Earth,
available to make space
for all.
MALE SPEAKER: So this is a
bit of a different event.
It's taking entrepreneurs,
and tech people,
and people really of
all walks of life.
What attracted you to
this event in particular?
YVONNE CAGLE: I
think just the fact
that there was so much that
was new and cutting edge,
and that there was a community
that's being galvanized around
this conversation.
And how open everybody is
to sharing their ideas.
So that you can be
absolutely bodacious to think
and to actually demonstrate
that you can get-- for example,
in our case-- the equivalent
of two hours of exercise,
both aerobic and anaerobic,
in less than 20 minutes.
That's mind blowing,
but you've got
to be able to think out
of the box, off planet,
and have the boldness to dare to
go to the edge of that envelope
and engage it.
And I see entrepreneurs who
have that kind of boldness
and determination.
And if that's something that we
could pack into a solid rocket
booster, we would be to
Pluto and back by now.
MALE SPEAKER: That's-- yeah.
So I believe I read
that you had in the past
worked as a liaison between
big companies like Google
in a role of figuring out
how you work with their data
and commercialization.
What did that role entail?
YVONNE CAGLE: Wow.
Well, we very much
were-- I should say,
rooted in the environment
and the atmosphere.
So much of our time
was spent trying
to demonstrate and evolve
tools that could help us
with clean tech,
with climate change,
being able to detect--
you know-- CO2 footprints.
And, very importantly,
was disaster preparedness,
how we could use imaging
to survey disaster areas,
and triage or prioritize
our resources in order
to do rescues.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
really interesting.
So, do you have a favorite
Google technology?
YVONNE CAGLE: Well I'm all
about mobility-- mobility
of the human body, getting
people back to moving,
be it within their
own physiology
or innovated exoskeletons
or vehicles themselves.
So for me, when
I think mobility,
I think anything from a
driverless vehicle-- so for me,
that autonomous vehicle with
Google is absolutely amazing.
And you can take that
and you can put it
into maybe even a space
shuttle that wants
to land on an asteroid someday.
So it's a great
demonstration capability.
But the most important
lesson I think
is knowing that we all
have our own spacecraft--
that we don't really
even need a vehicle.
We are our own craft, and if
we take it to space-- well,
that's Mach 25 all over
the place and back.
MALE SPEAKER: That's awesome.
Well, thank you very much
for joining me today.
YVONNE CAGLE: Great, thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks.
YVONNE CAGLE: Take care.
[MUSIC PLAYING]